this morning we are hearing from the CN
you were to jump yes my question do I
new in fragile ego is that the precipice
of collapse alright back to the news
this morning we're hearing from the 61
year old Nebraska woman who gave birth
to her own granddaughter after carrying
the baby for her son and his husband uma
Louise Doherty elledge was born last
week and weighed 5 pounds 13 ounces her
parents are matthew eledge and elliott
dougherty as Meg Oliver shows us her
conception was a family affair in many
ways uma Louise Doherty elledge is a
typical newborn she sleeps eats and
cries but the story behind her birth is
far from ordinary I love my mom he loves
his mother-in-law and she's gone to
extreme cases to get finally get a
grandkid around here matthew eledge is
mother Cecile did go to extreme lengths
she's not just his grandmother she also
carried the newborn as a surrogate we'd
always ask him reference to me like well
what are the chances of this and they'd
say we don't have a textbook on a 61
year old having a baby and the family
ties don't stop there when they wanted
to start a family I knew that it was no
doubt I wanted to help Elliot
Daugherty's sister Leah was the egg
donor and Matthew donated the sperm all
we knew is we wanted to be a family
it just all just kind of kept happening
in this like beautiful sort of like
serendipitous way it has to be my mom
like you know it was actually the other
way they were the ones that kind of
convinced us that this was a safe
decision grandmother Cecile underwent
numerous tests and regular hormone
injections to guarantee she was healthy
enough to be the surrogate she says it
wasn't always easy to be pregnant at 61
I would have to keep visualizing okay
but when the day comes when I can
deliver her and hand her off to her
parents that is going to be such a gift
that I am honored to be able to
of them as for uma her father say the
unconventional process behind this
little miracle has strengthened their
family bond I know this is a unique
situation but I'm so proud of the
creativity and the support and the love
that made this happen you know I think
she should feel really special that it
literally took a village to bring her
into this world for CBS this morning Meg
Oliver that's right it would take a
village we talked about this yesterday
where I said I would do it in a
heartbeat for my children I know Nora I
would - where - I wouldn't have to be in
my 60s I don't know pregnant yeah